I wrote a blog when the Marissa Meyer
decision came out that she that all
hands back on deck and if you can't hack
it quit I I was so emotional about it
that I actually wrote a blog it was on
The Daily Beast and that that was their
title
you know yahoo has it all wrong I
wouldn't have said it quite that way but
you know titles or titles I think that
it's clear that yahoo has a problem they
you know by some reports they're people
who aren't logging into their computer
and there's a lot of people aren't being
as engaged productive as as they should
be and they're not really working as
hard and the second problem is that they
need all creativity they need
collaboration they need innovation to
surge ahead as as a company I think that
Marissa Meyer used a blunt instrument to
tackle the two problems that are clearly
problems that is if you she did an
all-or-nothing thing no more flexibility
you know well if you've got people who
aren't performing that's a management
issue that's a performance issue if
people are not logging in if people
aren't working very hard and that can
happen whether or not they're in the
office for working remotely then you
deal with that you set performance
standards you make sure that they live
up to their performance standards and if
they don't they get fired but if they do
you give them a or they can you give
them a chance to improve if you need
collaboration and you need co-op you
know innovation then you can't just
assume that it's going to happen by
people bumping into each other at the
proverbial water cooler or coffee cup or
whatever in the office you have to
create a forum to promote collaboration
and some of that collaboration
absolutely happens by people seeing each
other bumping into each other running
into the next office or cubicle or open
space or however the the workspace is
set up and saying I have this idea what
do you think but some of it actually
happens alone why do we have our bed
style ideas in the shower when we're
taking the dog for a walk or you know I
I'm struggling with something it doesn't
come to me in a group discussion I have
a group discussion but then it comes to
me alone and again it's this
all-or-nothing approach you need
FaceTime you need people to be together
but you also need people to have space
and time where they can focus where they
can be not distracted and where they can
pursue an idea and you can use actually
they're a technology company you can use
technology to do that IBM has world jams
they will have a really tough a real
problem you know a not a made-up problem
but a real problem they'll put it out to
their network who has good ideas for
solving this problem and then they'll
take some of the best ideas and form
teams around them so you can in that
that's across the globe so you don't
always have to be together to create
innovation I think that what I expect
Yahoo to learn is that they're going to
have to provide some some flexibility I
mean I've been looking at some of the
blog's that Yahoo people have been you
know writing in this was leaked
obviously by disgruntled employees and
you know they're saying okay if I have
to be in the office at this time does
that mean that I'm not working at night
you know so those boundaries again
aren't real clear I expect that Yahoo
will move back to a little bit of
flexibility well managed what what
flexibility has to work for the employer
and has to work for the employee it's
not an all-or-nothing most people do not
work at home all the time if they are
allowed to most they work very
sporadically at home so it's you know
there are only three percent of the u.s.
workforce who actually work at home on a
very regular basis it's a very small
proportion more likely to be men than
women by the way
you